j'accueille maintenant didier lestrade
[Musique]
hier à bonsoir vous êtes journaliste à
têtu cofondateur de l'acteur est déjà
publié deux livres chez denoël dont act
up une histoire et vous publié
aujourd'hui 10 end
toujours chez denoël vous partez d'un
constat simple depuis l'arrivée des
trithérapies né en 1996 le sida ne fait
plus peur c'est ce qui explique le
phénomène du bareback alors le bareback
pour nous inviter les spectateurs qui ne
seraient pas au courant c'est l'abandon
de la capote c c'est un nouveau style de
vie après 25 ans d'épidémie ou des gens
sont fatigués de la capote et finissent
par revendiquer le fait de refuser la
capote et je crois que ce livre c'était
la première fois qu'on fait un livre sur
la prévention minutes et parce que je
suis très inquiet de ça c'est quelque
chose qui après 15 ans 2 d'activision me
fait beaucoup de mal et de voir que
l'épidémie reprend chez les homosexuels
c'est forcément un moment bien sûr c'est
un sujet grave mais c'est un moment
c'est quelque chose
c'est un sujet qui mérite quand même
qu'on s'insurge et non seulement à
l'intérieur de son propre groupe c'est à
dire que moi je me suis toujours battu
dans la lutte contre le sida et et je
suis un peu triste quand je vois que les
choses commencent à 1 à tourner mal
oui quand au niveau de bouquins dans la
pression s'est un peu rien ne va plus
chez les homos la communauté perd ses
repères quoi on s'est un peu excusez moi
il ya une morale quoi les jeunes par
exemple qui arrive à 20 ans ils n'ont
pas vraiment connu ce qu'on a connu nous
moi je suis séropo depuis 17 ans et
c'est vrai que même quelqu'un de mon âge
c'est très difficile de parler à un
jeune et de leur expliquer en quoi c'est
vraiment important de rester sur ses
roues négatif et qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour se protéger et c'est vrai que
moi ça fait depuis cinq ans six ans que
je vois cette idée de bareback grandir
de plus en plus dans la communauté gay à
un moment on a cru que c'était un
pantalon
c'était un délire de ma part et je crois
que maintenant on a des chiffres qui
montrent que d'année en année ça
augmente dans tous les pays qui sont
autour de chez nous et je crois que 20 %
d'augmentation en angleterre l'année
dernière pour une seule année ça veut
dire que il suit cinq ans comme ça lyon
double non
de calce il l'hébergeait coeur pour vous
c'est un petit peu des kamikazes quoi
des kamikazes nihiliste qui disent après
moi le déluge il ya une partie des gens
qui ont vraiment envie d'être d'être ni
liste oui ben il ya aussi des gens tout
simplement qu'ils baissent les bras
d'asse les bras parce que c'est vraiment
très dur de considérer que tous les
jours il faut mettre la capote et je
crois que la prévention était vraiment
dans une situation vraiment de crise en
france c'est à dire que les associations
je crois ont baissé la garde vraiment et
je crois que l'état en profite et que du
coup à partir du moment parle pas de
prévention et bien les gens sont
désemparés ils savent vraiment pas ce
qu'il faut faire mais le sentiment qu'on
a dit dédé sera si vous êtes une morale
dont tout ça et on revient à un petit
peu sur la problématique développer ce
rallye si la semaine dernière c'est à
dire il ya une homosexualité subversive
et nouveau sexualité normative des xes
plutôt partisan de la seconde mais non
parce que j'ai 46 ans je fais partie de
la limo sexualité subversives
mais c'était avant l'arrivée du sida ça
va être subversif aujourd'hui qu'il ya
42 millions de personnes qui sont
touchées par cette maladie
c'est quand même pas possible on s'est
battu moi je me suis battu pendant 13
ans pour qu'ils aient des traitements
j'ai rencontré tous les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques en fait si l'on
travaille à octobre j'ai fais chier les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et le
gouvernement est maintenant qu'on a les
traitements qu'on est dans un pays où on
a la chance d'avoir les traitements il
ya des mecs qui veulent être subversif
en disant je vais oublier la capote
c'est pas de la subversion c'est tout
simplement de la connerie est un moment
il faut le rappeler que fait non
seulement un respect de soi même mais un
respect des autres mal
alors
bien moins un poil sur le ciel ghz il
est rasé d'accord avec alain soral
c'est l'obsession des guides pour le
pour le shopping et le consumérisme le
guet alain soral dit la seule chose qui
fait qu'il ya une communauté
homosexuelle fait le shopping et moi je
dis il ya d'autres choses quand même il
ya non seulement le fait qu'on a fait
partie d'une minorité qui a mal vécu
pendant pas mal de temps et qui est
encore y'a pas longtemps il ya un mec
dans le nord qui s'appelle sébastien
sébastien boucher qui a été brûlé vif
et ça c'est de la vraie homophobie réel
1 est ce que je veux dire là dessus il
faut pas imaginer que la vie maintenant
elle est complètement facile pour les
homosexuels je crois que le consumérisme
c'est peut-être une façon de vivre les
choses plus vite quand peut-être on a
plus d'incertitudes sur l'avenir
ouais et je crois que quand même fait
pas une excuse quand même pour oublier
de s'engager sur des choses qui sont
importantes
c'est à dire le sida actuellement il ya
très peu de gens qui sont intéressés par
ce sujet mais je crois que sur un sujet
pareil on est obligé d'avoir des gens
qui de temps en temps à bajus un vrai
parti souhaitait plus déçu c'est le
sentiment qu'on a roulé dans votre livre
déçu parce que finalement dans la
communauté gay l'individualisme a
remplacé l'idéalisme je crois oui un peu
mais je crois que c'est un peu le
principe d'immersion je crois qu'il faut
que les gens aillent mal pour qu'ils se
ressaisissent et je crois que c'est ce
qui s'est passé au début du sida ou
savez les gens se sont mobilisés au
début du sida parce qu'ils avaient peur
mais les gens se sont pas pris la capote
parce que c'était fans ils ont pris la
pac à la capote simplement parce qu'il
avait vraiment peur d'ouvrir et je crois
que maintenant les gens ont oublié ce
que c'est cette maladie le monde même il
suffit de voir mon visage il est marqué
et tout ça mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que vous voyez plus maintenant des
images de malades à la tenue nous vous
en voyez plus est là dans les bureaux et
à partir du moment où les trithérapies
sont arrivés c'est vrai qu'on a commencé
à dire bondam les médias ont été
contents de considérer que c'est un
sujet qu'on pouvait mettre de côté vous
pouvoir parler notre sueur mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya plus cet enthousiasme qui
avait au départ vous dites par exemple
la banalisation du sexe vous citer un
exemple dans votre bouquin vous arrivez
dans un mini bar cuir il ya un mec qui
est en train de sucer à un autre en se
faisant qu il continue à discuter comme
si de rien n'était
vous dites que finalement une espèce de
banalisation du truc aux axonais mais il
ya surtout des rapports qui sont plus
difficile maintenant entre homosexuels
et je crois que c'est le fond du
problème c'est le fond de ce livre
pourquoi l'épidémie reprend chez les
homosexuels c'est parce que je crois que
ils sont très durs les uns entre envers
les autres et ils se ils ont des
systèmes de drague maintenant qu'ils
sont vraiment qu'ils passent pas par le
dialogue qu'ils passent pas par 20 on
n'a pas envie de savoir tisser
on n'a pas envie de se connaître iliad
vachement demain qui ont vraiment très
peur de tomber amoureux aujourd'hui
c'est quand même le monde à l'envers si
la culture du back room où on y va pour
mais la culture du sexe qui est
disponible qui est bien mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça a eu un effet un
peu pervers c'est à dire que cette
banalisation du sexe a fait que
maintenant les gens ont vraiment du mal
à communiquer et je crois que enfin on
le sait que je sais bien mais c'est
quand même juste un moyen quand même
l'idée c'est quand même de pouvoir se
rencontrer et de pouvoir un moment quand
vous avez peur de parler à quelqu'un
parce que vous avez l'impression que
vous parlez trop ou peut-être vous dit
pas les choses qu'il faut faire je veux
dire ça veut dire que les rapports des
drags les rapports de communication
commence à être un peu un peu perverti
je crois en mai quand je dis vous êtes
déçu c'est vrai même la musique vous
dites maintenant la musique pour vous
est passée au second plan
vous dites qu'elle était aussi aliénante
que le bareback finalement même
journaliste qui a beaucoup parlé de à
millery assuré que je vois que c'est
vrai que c'est une musique et peut-être
pas assez respecté mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que on peut penser que j'ai
un discours comme ça très moralisateur
mais c'est pas moralisateur sais de la
morale et la morale c'est n'est pas
forcément quelque chose de mal dans la
sexualité c'est simplement c'est on a
envie tout simplement de bien traiter
les gens un essai et ça veut pas dire
non plus de d'être non plus ne est
complètement idiot je crois que l'on
peut avoir de tout dans un monde et
quand je crois que cette façon de se
comporter d'une manière très dur ça
devient de vie
la normalité pour moi je suis obligée
d'intervenir parce que j'ai 46 ans et je
suis obligé de rappeler comment c'était
il ya un temps il ya dix ans ou quand
même mesures devant être gay ben c'était
un peu plus sympa oui et c'est parti
entre l'ailé gazoline est paradoxal
parce que les avantages des gués
maintenant son énorme envie vraiment
mieux mais c'est paradoxal un moment où
on vit mieux que les homosexuels entre
ce traitement bien ils sont du mal alors
il reste du monde leur en fait moi c'est
ça qui est le grand paradoxe de solides
en pensez-quoi gerrard c'est est ce que
pourrait dire d'effondrement des valeurs
d'une certaine façon dans les valeurs
homosexuels en tous les cas les valeurs
de la communauté gay on parle des
backrooms des choses comme ça je pense
que c'est très parisien est prêt
citadins il ya plein de gens qui parce
que c'est donc aussi des homosexuels qui
ils ont faim dans les backrooms bien sûr
mais qui en se mettant des doigts et des
bains et des machins et qui fait mais
est qui et qui font l'amour normalement
quoi oui il a fait il n'y a pas un
ghetto autant de ghettos qu'on peut
penser voilà ce que non mais ce que je
vais dire à partir du moment où si vous
vous savez dans un mois il va y avoir
les premiers chiffres officiels ont tiré
sur son fils dans un mois vous avez une
remontée vraiment effective de
l'épidémie chaise d'homosexuels que vous
alliez dans les backrooms quoi tout le
monde sera vraiment concerné plus qu'en
fait c'est vrai qu'il ya une façon sam
d'être homosexuel et la façon d'act up
qui était très militante trop militants
attendent et on n'a jamais été trop
militant n'oubliez pas qu'en france on a
réussi à influencer la distribution des
médicaments qui ont sauvé des dizaines
de milliers de vies et vous pouvez dire
il ya bien sûr extrêmes ne peut pas être
bon
et d'ailleurs je passe une grande partie
de mon bouquin à les critiquer mais ce
que je veux dire en tout cas sur les
traitements on a fait un boulot qui est
vraiment exemplaire dans le monde
exemple vous êtes un peu et josé bové le
jackpot mais oui c'est pour ça je
l'admiré bien quelqu'un vous n'irez pas
du tout hein c'est eric rey m ben oui
parce que je crois que c'est l'un des
deux un des deux écrivains homosexuels
qui a fait qui a basé sa carrière sur le
fait de dire qu' abandonner la capote
c'était plutôt fans et moi en tant que
militant je ne peux pas accepter ça je
suis obligé de me
en colère
il est l'arbitré m
[Musique]
sms journaliste libération dans un hamac
guettier auteur notamment de serial
fucker journal d'un becker en 2003 aux
éditions blanche où vous expliquer
comment plomber un partenaire tout à
fait donc ça c'était un roman donc
soutenu il ya un an et demi expliqué les
problèmes du bareback dans la communauté
gay j'ai fait ce fut mon pouvoir de
renseignements et de l'information
je suis journaliste depuis 15 ans je
bossais à guêpier cantier qu'andy a été
agréé pied aussi après j'ai fait les
articles dont je suivais les inusables
d'act up de pour mes relations
donc j'ai toujours fait un travail de
prévention c'est à dire qu'à un moment
on pouvait vous soupçonnez de faire
l'apologie du bareback en expliquant
exactement comment il allait faire pour
couper le bout de la capote pour faire
un trou avec une aiguille pour être sûr
de contaminer son partenaire et
aujourd'hui visité en fait j'ai fait
tout ça pour pau s'est entouré raison de
préhension
c'est un travail de journaliste que
j'avais fait aussi jeudi ce qui se passe
exactement dans certaines backrooms
comme comme didier le fait est là mais
en fait d'accord il s'agit d une honte
c'est trop facile d'écrire des trucs lé
dans les bouquins il n'est pas fait à
télé pour dire c'est juste un roman je
veux dire tous les [ __ ] qui connaissent
et connaissent rms vont sur son site et
c'est qu'il est et il sait ce qu'il a
écrit
il a encore donné interio anneaux où il
disait que ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils baiser sans capote qui chope et
toutes les médecins du monde qui se sont
contaminées et qui disait grosso modo
que c'était tout à fait couler ce qu'ils
ont été la carrière vous avez dit
attendez alors grâce à matri 12
milliards tout ça et donc je vous
permets de faire ce que je veux c'est
vrai vous l'avez écrit dans le ciel mais
revient sur le droit de parler de ce qui
me plaisait sans capote et dans le iv
est alors beaucoup de militants d'act up
on explique aussi la manche moi je suis
pas là pour parler du sida toute façon
je suis en plus je ne préfère pas parler
avec didier lestrade puisqu'il ya un
quoi parce que dans la mesure où je
crois le pas aux fascistes de manière
généralement reconnus par et
et deuxièmement c'est un gars vous êtes
d'accord avec ça une procédure à une
procédure judiciaire parce que act up a
saccagé les bureaux de mon éditeur ou
des éditions blanche et donc il ya une
procédure en cours dont sherpa je passe
je souhaite pas parler de ce à quoi est
un schisme dans l'internaute grave mais
c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile c'est à dire que
pendant des années vous savez à chaque
fois que j'ai sorti un bouquin il me
disait merci d'avoir parlé de moi parce
que tu as fais ma promo donc il faut pas
être aussi cynique que ça c'est à dire
le mec il a fait vraiment son beurre sur
le bareback il ya des gens qui ont lu
ses bouquins il ya sûrement des gens qui
sont devenus séropositifs aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont tellement désemparés
ils ont pensé que c'était une option
possible d'affronter le sida en se
comptent en minant d'une manière voulue
et maintenant on est en train de dire
que c'est des romans de cette route
facile tu vois c'est le même discours
que tu as mais non leur mort il est sur
le même mois je suis le roman j'ai
toujours dit la même chose
la rue moi j'aimerais bien que je n'ai
pas un double discours mais c'est vrai
aussi
didier vous conviendrez que en dehors
des romans et notamment sérieux coeur le
roman de notre avenir m s le plus grand
sectionne guide par irm un rayon de
vidéos bareback donc il n'est pas le
seul responsable qu'envoyer j'ai fait
des articles nom est tu pour dénoncer ça
exactement comme j'ai fait des articles
dans têtu pour dénoncer le fait que dans
l'est dans les clubs n'y avait pas assez
de prévention
je veux dire là dessus on a fait un
travail énorme et un moment erika était
plutôt du côté des teneurs de back room
parce qu'ils étaient super copain avec
eux alors qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de
prévention dans les sous-sols moi je
suis contre toute répression de la
sexualité
didier lestrade c'est un petit peu la
marine le pen des backrooms
donc moi chuté je suis content du
système de répression
je suis un révolutionnaire du sexe un
libérateur de la sexualité c'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit des guides sur la
sexualité ça fait 15 ans que je parle de
sexualité
là je sors un nouveau bouquin qui
s'appelle ou six guides ça fait 450 pas
il est très délicate dans laquelle on
explique aux hétéros comment y remédier
ferrer sexuelle c'est à dire si un peu
défriser un bouquin qui hésite et ont
été commencées les berjalliens qui
laisse parler directement géré en pensez
quoi
moi j'écoute pas et il faut faire parler
de terreur était un peu bavé sur tara
qui est la ferme quand on entend ce que
j'entends je suis bien à terek avec dix
mois je baise sans capote et je suis
content de le dire on ne peut pas
inviter stéphanie fugain pour parler de
la leucémie on veut pas parler du
sidaction la semaine dernière et les
fêtards et un mec non les préparer un
mec je suis pas idiot de dire moi je
baise sans capote et j'en suis fier et
j'ai le droit de penser
moi je trouve ça une honte et jls est
essentielle
[Applaudissements]
on peut
quand vous l'avez sol avec sa mère loin
de là mais enfin on peut aussi dire que
le meilleur moyen de 10,3 et c'est un
des meilleurs moyens de lutter contre le
bareback c'est aussi de dire que nérac
interroge un gain perros guirec et c'est
parce que c'est quelqu'un sur lui ce
qu'il entend il entend bareback que
c'est parce qu est ce qu il croit que
c'est un airbag qu un truc de bagnols et
à côté de ça il entend un mec si l'édile
baisse sans capote c'est inadmissible ce
qu'on entend là c'est inadmissible ce
qu'on entend là si on doit le faire
taire c'est une amnistie à la pige aux
éditions avant moi j'ai juste une
question c'est que pour vous les bonnes
questions
moi ce qui m'intrigue c'est dû y penser
quand exemple jouer avec votre vie
c'est vrai qu'elle vous appartient mais
ce qui est si penser quand même de deux
peut-être
voilà je joue avec la vie des autres des
personnes un peu innocente naïve et
c'est dommage que la vie cette personne
soit complètement vie après ça
[Applaudissements]
car sans le jura jacquet avec butin je
crois que je crois qu'on témoignant à la
télé en ayant le courage aussi le dire
ce que je dis est d'informer les gens
c'est une manière de prévenir
donc ils sont enfin vous déguiser un peu
c'est a priori c'est votre gagne pain et
vous déguiser ça monsieur parle de
prévention ou fait du fric sur moi c'est
la prévention radical maintenant c'est
dégueulasse selon moi il calme et non
pas du tout
oui quand j'avais les choses qu'il
fallait vraiment pas faire ça passe à la
prévention à prendre soin au stade oui
mais le roman d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est d'après ce que condamnent
ce que condamnent didier en racontant ce
qui se passe dans les backrooms moi je
lui en ai parlé il ya un an et demi en
en faisant un roman c'est la même chose
mais toi de la vie active rsa et si oui
est ce que tu sais que tu vas connaître
contaminer d'autres que moi je suis
mariée avec un mec qui serait négative
depuis trois ans on essaie savez je n'ai
pas concède me n'ai pas envie de parler
dit j'ai pas envie d'être avec depuis
deux ans tu l'as dit dans une autre
interview faut savoir et puis de toute
façon attend le bouquin que tu as sorti
sur le bareback c'était il ya un an
et puisque tu as fait dans les années
précédentes tu viens on va pas commencer
à te demander vraiment site a contaminé
les gens mais commence pas à dire que
c'est des trucs du genre c'est une
histoire ancienne
il ya des gens qui sont séropositifs
aujourd'hui et tu devrais tu peux pas
tout simplement considérer que c'est un
coup que tu as eue il ya dix ans ou mais
moi j'ai informé les gens venir si tu
tellement il avait laminé ly gens avec
une ordure j'ai pas contaminer des
ombres
vous avez contaminer des gens qui a
mangé par les dernières sinon comment tu
peux dire est inconsciemment avions plus
[Musique]